on Friday the US government reported
that the economy has continued to grow
at a 2 percent annual rate despite
growing concerns of a future recession
next a discussion on politics and
economics with Niall Ferguson professor
of political and financial history at
England's Oxford University and author
of the cash Nexus money and power in the
modern world 1700 to 2000 it's about an
hour good afternoon my name is Charles
caption I'm a senior fellow here at the
council and I have the pleasure of
presiding at today's luncheon event our
speaker today is Neil Ferguson he will
be discussing his new book the cash
Nexus money and power in the modern
world 1700 to 2000 recently published by
basic books neil is currently a
professor of political and financial
history at Oxford University and also a
visiting professor professor of
economics at the Stern School of
Business New York University he is the
author of paper and iron the House of
Rothschild the pity of war and virtual
history and he is currently working on a
major new history of the British Empire
since Neil is one of the most prolific
authors around we're expecting this new
book by the end of next week let me also
say that Neil was here about a year and
a half ago to discuss his book a pity
war on World War one my blood pressure
is still elevated from that discussion
of Germany's role in the war I must be a
glutton for punishment because I'm
coming back for more
anyway it's my pleasure to to welcome
Neil to the Council
well I'm sorry about your blood pressure
Johnny I'll try and do something to
bring it down perhaps I should say sorry
in Chinese not accepted try again
you have no hostages um it's a great
pleasure to be back at the Council on
Foreign Relations and thank you to ever
be responsible for inviting me and thank
you to everyone who's come for the
quickest lunch in town today I want to
begin with a brief explanation of the
title of my book the cash Nexus when I
first proposed toning the book the cash
Nexus a number of people in London
looked surprised and said but I thought
that was a make of car and I spent a
good deal of time trying to persuade
people that the word Nexus which is AB
Latin origin means essentially a nought
or link was an appropriate word for a
book about the relationship between
finance and politics believer the theme
of the book like me it's a phrase that
comes from Scotland was Thomas Carlyle
who coined it in 1840 when he wrote a
wonderful essay on past and present
entitled in which he argued and I'll
summarize his argument that cash payment
was not the sole nexus between man and
man Carlyle sense was that the incipient
industrialization of Britain and indeed
the world threatened to transform all
human relationships into economic
relationships and his argument was
against that that the cash Nexus was not
the sole relation between people and in
a way that the underlying theme of the
book which sets out to question the
primacy of economics or the primacy of
finance in political life
and not only in international relations
but also in domestic politics going
right back to the early 18th century and
in some cases further back than that
it's also a book which attempts to
address a Tolstoy n' question Tolstoy is
great question at the end of warrant
peace is what is power and that's really
the key question that I found myself
addressing inspired by Carlisle I was
asking is power financial power does
money really makes the world go round
as I think we've all come perhaps only
subconsciously to assume it's the
economy stupid a phrase that must haunt
Al Gore as he tries to understand what
went wrong when according to every model
of electoral success that the political
scientists have produced he should have
romped home to to a landslide at the end
of last year what I want to talk about
today before our discussion and I'm
going to try and keep it as brief as
possible so that we have ample time for
discussion is the International aspect
of the book I'll spare you
elections I think election fatigue is
probably fairly well established in the
u.s. today I want to address very
briefly three of the questions in the
book first
is there a harmonious relationship
between democracy and capitalism between
democratization and the spread of free
markets are they a kind of magical
double helix a virtuous upward spiral
should we be confident about the future
as both the free market and democracy
appear to be spreading inexorably around
the world my second question how far is
it possible to have economic
globalization without
kind of political global power without
to use a very dirty word imperialism and
finally is there a danger of
overstretch that all great powers must
be fearful of a question raised in my
mind some years ago by Paul Kennedy's
splendid book the rise and fall of the
great powers to which in some senses the
cash Nexus is an extended report if we
go back as far as it's possible to go
back in the history of per-capita income
and the history of democratization there
is at least a clear coincidence between
the rise of per capita income and the
spread of democratic institutions around
the world back in 1800 if you do the
numbers some excellent economic
historians have heroics they attempted
to do per capita income expressed in
1990 dollars was about two hundred and
fifty dollars this is for the world as a
whole the average annual income of an
individual in the world in 1800 today
it's risen exponentially to two thousand
five hundred an extraordinary growth
most of which occurred in the 20th
century in fact and there's a similar
upward curve if one tracks the spread of
democratic institutions around the world
there's a wonderful database the polity
3 database I discovered which attempts
to quantify the spread of democracy
since 1800 and apart from some rather
alarming interruptions in the 1930s and
1940s it looks like another upward
ascent back in 1800 according to their
scale of how democratic are you marks
out of 10 no countries scored above 6
out of 10
in the last few years for the first time
in history more than half of countries
in the world score above 6 out of 10 on
the democracy scale so it looks like a
happy ending and that I suppose was one
of the arguments Francis Fukuyama made
in the end of history now in the book I
try to suggest that this coincidence of
the spread of of prosperity and the
spread of democracy needs to be looked
at very much more closely than it has
been before we conclude that there is
some happy causal relationship one way
or the other between economic growth and
democratization but I don't want to
label that point today for me the really
critical argument and the one that means
the ending is not necessarily happy and
isn't an ending is the fact that
democratization appears to be associated
in many parts of the world with an
increase of internal conflicts within
multi-ethnic societies and this seems to
me to be the fundamental catch
underlying the spread of prosperity and
the spread of democratization it's a
catch I could illustrate very easily
with another wonderful upward ascending
chart only this time the rising curve
measures the number of civil wars in the
world for most of history certainly
going back into the 1800s civil war was
the exception most wars were between
states and the number of civil wars in
the world was around 5 on average for
most of the 19th century sometimes a
little more but today and this has been
true only for around 10 years the
majority of wars in the world are civil
wars they are wars within States very
often wars which have their origins in
ethnic conflict is this simply a
coincidence rising prosperity rising
democratization and increasing civil war
I don't think it is there's some very
illuminating work by Harvard political
scientist Alberto Alice ena which argues
that this is not so surprising that as
democratic institutions come to
multi-ethnic societies from Yugoslavia
to Indonesia one of the first things
that happens is that instead of falling
into the kind of peacefully resolved
herbal parliamentary disputes that we
expect as Britons and Americans to
happen under democracy what happens is
that conflicts between ethnic groups
very quickly take on a violent character
and cannot be resolved through
parliamentary debate much the same
happened and explains the great crisis
of democracy in Central and Eastern
Europe in the 1920s and 1930s so we have
in a sense been here before
democratization appears to be associated
when we take the global view with
increasing civil conflict and as a
consequence with political fragmentation
and political fragmentation is one of
the great problems of our time and it is
an inevitable consequence of the
proliferation of civil war back in the
time of Bismarck
there were about 60 recognisable States
political States nation-states empires
call them what you will as of today the
number is closer to 190 and rising even
we Scots have to contemplate the
alarming possibility that in our own
lifetimes we may find ourselves the
People's Republic of Caledonia prospects
that terrifies me and should tell or
terrify the English even more this in
other words is the catch simply giving
the world prosperity and democracy may
not necessarily and appears not to lead
to a happy ending they don't all live
happily ever after on the contrary as
Dostoyevsky said wonderfully they fight
and fight and fight and fight and that
he said was the one certainty in human
history
this it seems to me has profound
implications for globalization that
buzzword of our times now much of the
literature on the history of
globalization seeks to draw parallels
between globalization 100 years ago the
last great age of commercial and
financial global integration and
globalization today what I want to do
very briefly is to suggest some of the
key differences not only in the
economics of globalization but also in
the politics of globalization comparing
pre-1914 or let us say 1901 with 2001
the biggest difference of all seems to
me to lie in the different roles played
by what we laughingly called the top
nation in 1066 and all that Britain as
top nation had a quite different
relationship with the rest of the world
compared with the relationship between
the United States and the rest of the
world today in economic terms it is a
striking fact that exports that trade
with the rest of the world played a
vastly bigger role in the British
economy in 1900 then it plays even today
in the US economy
25 percent of gross national product was
roughly what exports accounted for for
Britain before the First World War
compare that with a figure of around 7
or so percent in recent years in the US
and even more importantly Britain was a
great capital exporter the world's
banker lending investing abroad on a
colossal scale yet today's global
hegemon the United States is a great
borrower the world's great debtor if you
look at net foreign investment as a
proportion of gross domestic product
from Britain before the first world war
it was a positive 9 percent a colossal
level of capital export but the United
States in the last 10 or so years
has shifted into being the greatest
death the same figure the equivalent
figure fur net foreign investment as a
proportion of gross domestic product is
minus 15% for the u.s. today
so the global hegemon today is not a
great lender not a great investor but a
great borrower ordering from abroad to
finance the greatest consumption boom in
all of history and a third important
economic difference once upon a time the
global hegemon exported people a
colossal level of migration out of the
British Isles lay behind that
transformation of the world economy that
occurred in the 18th and 19th centuries
even on the eve of the first world war
between 6 & 8 per thousand of the
British population emigrated each year
of course I don't need to tell you that
the United States is a mirror image of
Britain before the first world war today
the United States is an importer of
people as well as of cash now in
discussions of globalization that is
usually where the story stops trade
finance migration but I want to
emphasize the importance of exporting
and globalizing institutions this was
something about the which the British
were never at all embarrassed and yet it
seems to me that perhaps this follows
logically from what I've said about the
different economic roles played by
Britain and America the export of
American institutions is happening if
it's happening at all in a far more
informal way than the export of British
institutions in the 18th and 19th
centuries the Pax Britannica was based
on the formal direct rule of about a
quarter of the world's population and a
quarter of the world's land surface area
I was trying to devise a way of
comparing British formal power with
American informal par today and I was
trying to find a map that I could
compare with those wonderful maps that
all British classrooms used to have
of the world colors pink no such maps
appear to exist with as it were a tiny
little pink basis to characterize
America's formal Empire so eventually I
found out that there are approximately
70 military bases overseas which the US
Armed Forces presently maintain in fact
nearly half of them are in Western
Europe and the overwhelming majority are
in Germany and indeed a Martian looking
at this imaginary map of American formal
rule would conclude that the principal
objective of American foreign policy in
the year 2001 is to control Germany
clearly the most potent threat to US
interests today this is a tremendously
anachronistic distribution of resources
that have been dwindling rapidly since
the mid 1980s one of them are striking
statistics that the cache Nexus has to
offer is that the wars between the mid
80s and the late 90s in real terms a
decline in American military expenditure
of the order of a third at a time when
the need to drastically reinstate
American foreign policy
probably logically demanded higher
rather than lower expenditure we are in
the midst of an enormous period of
restructuring but this restructuring it
seems to me in American foreign and
defense policy is being done on the
cheap the question I find myself
addressing when I posed the Tolstoy in
question what is power came back to Paul
Kennedy's theory of the late 1980s that
the United States ran the risk of
Imperial overstretch he drew an explicit
parallel with Britain in the 1890s the
the weary title and yet it seems to me
as it did then to be a mistake to
imagine that the sources of British
decline lay in excesses imperial or
military commitments
and rather what I argue in the book is
that if we want to explain what went
wrong with British power in the 20th
century the better answer is that it lay
the problem lay in under stretch in the
failure of British liberal and
conservative politicians alike
adequately to prepare for the great
threat to British global power that was
being prepared in Germany from the 1890s
if not before under stretch lead the
British Empire open to an assault
through the backdoor through Belgium
towards the channel which it was fully
in equipped to repulse and the costs of
which in the course of the First World
War rendered the British Empire from
that moment on are profoundly
financially vulnerable at institution
under stretch in other words is the
danger that great powers face not
overstretch and I try to show in the
book that it's a myth that excessive
military expenditure has ever posed a
threat to the United States economy far
more serious is the risk the risk that
the British ran that in complacently
assuming that you dominate the globe you
underestimate the dangers that are
developing not so far from your own
backdoor and this brings me to my
concluding reflection it's a reflection
which has moral as well as a pragmatic
financial tinge to us the question that
I find myself asking as I completed the
cash Nexus as I contemplated the
enormous material wealth of American
Society of Americans as individuals was
simply this Americans clearly have the
cash they have the resources but do they
have the will in fact in the book I
wrote the gas
to make the world a better place by
analogy in the way that the British
Empire sought however unsuccessfully to
export British institutions even to
those Dodd forsaken parts of Africa that
we all know on the map but never visit
even by analogy with that Carlisle got
it right
cash he wrote later has not all power
and those Americans who imagine that
here on planet Nasdaq they are for the
future seen EDA a global superpower
without rival may be in danger of
succumbing to that great delusion that
ultimately sank British power thank you
very much for your attention
we will now turn to Q&A for the balance
of our time let me try to impose at
least a little bit of structure on the
conversation by suggesting that we spent
about 15 minutes on some of the broader
arguments that Neel makes about the
connection between power and finance
critique of the Democratic piece and
then turn to and segue into some of the
more contemporary claims that Neil is
putting forward particularly on the
nature of the American polity and the
claim that he ended with namely that the
United States should be willing to
expend more blood and treasure and
putting out Pax Americana but that it is
unwilling to do so is neo right in that
assessment and if so why and what can
should if anything be done about it
please when I call upon you state your
name your affiliation and pose a brief
question I would like to go first sir
could you wait for the microphone my
name is Joel Cohen I'm at Rockefeller in
Columbia University's I know I'd like to
ask whether you think that the rise in
civil wars which accompanied the rise in
incomes and the rise in democratization
could alternatively be explained as a
delayed echo of the collapse of
colonialism which drew borders around
countries without respect to the wishes
of the occupants of those countries and
put together people who were not well
disposed toward one another would that
be if that were an explanation then the
rise in civil wars would be a transient
effect until countries resource ensel
way but it is that plausible
it's a good question job I'm not
convinced that the answer is yes for one
simple reason that lurking behind your
question is is the great American
assumption that self-determination will
ultimately deliver the happy ending of
homogeneous nation states I think the
idea that absent colonialism somehow the
map of Africa would eventually have
formed into something more like a
patchwork quilt of smaller tribal
nation-states is a highly questionable
one and the notion that civil wars arise
because the borders are in the wrong
place is I think doing a violence to
what certainly the British attempted to
do as they decolonized let's take a an
obvious example of how borders were
drawn on the basis of self-determination
in the great scuttle from India over
which Mountbatten presided the problem
the great conflict that welled up at the
end of British rule in India was really
a consequence of the assumption that
there should be a kind of self
determining and religiously homogenous
partition of India now I think the
problem is very well illustrated again
if you look at Central Europe by the way
in which the peacekeepers at Versailles
assumed a shortcut took to harmony
would be to attempt to create self
determined nation-states in the rooms of
the Hapsburg and even the Ottoman Empire
problem is that the ethnic map of the
world just never was like that and the
question of how political units should
be drawn and how far they should be
based on self-determination seems to me
to be the big question that Western
policymakers in general have been
ducking for the better part of a hundred
years if the model is the homogeneous
ethnically homogeneous nation-state then
we have an awful lot more civil war to
come almost incalculable amount and a
great many more petty states do to be
formed I don't think that can be blamed
on in effects colonialism I think it can
be blamed on the application of the
principle of Maxine Ian's
self-determination and 19th century
European notions of nationalism and I
think our real failure and decolonizing
was to contemplate the possibility that
their ethnic Li homogeneous nation-state
was not the correct model for the rest
of the world even if it had been to
Western Europe placed in the back
Thank You fret tips and here at the
council I'm sure you're aware of the
argument in fact Foreign Affairs
published an article not long ago that
in fact the incidence of civil war has
actually gone down in the last ten years
not up and I wonder if you have a
response to that but my question has
more to do with the difference between
the position of Britain a hundred years
ago in the position of the United States
in the sense that Britain was faced with
the challenge to the system conducive to
its own security from great power
challenges the Germans and others in
Europe particular whereas isn't it the
case today that the United States with
all due respect to those who think that
China or even Europe may become great
power challenges to us the problem for
us and the system that is conducive to
our security is one of weakness and not
power it's that it's the collapse and
the deterioration of States not the
ascendance of great powers that's been
confronts us well I quite agree with
that second point on the question of the
incidence of civil war it's always a
mistake and here I speak as an historian
you must remember that I'm not an expert
on current affairs and I'd be violating
the trace description act if I came to
know much about the present I know about
the past and the one thing I do know is
that 10 years is not really a long
enough sub period for us to make any
generalizations about the incidence of
civil war like to talk about 200 years
and what one is most struck by when one
simply tries to add up the amount of
conflict within borders is this vast
increase in the period from around about
the mid 1980s and I don't think the Vick
line is anything like enough in the last
couple of years to justify talk of a
decline in civil war indeed I think
we're already seeing developing in
countries like Indonesia a whole new
wave of strife an ethnic nature which
will make Yugoslavia look like a teddy
bears picnic I mean the second question
you asked is is absolutely correctly
framed of course there are no great
power riders a rare
the Secretary of Defense's most recent
report to Congress the other day which
rather half-heartedly suggested in a
paragraph about future threats to
American power that the main contenders
were indeed China and Russia
and if if that is the most that the
United States has to worry about and we
can all relax and go home
clearly this is not a world like the
world of 1901 and one when already it
was clear that economically and
militarily a Britain faced serious
competition and not just from Germany
but also from Russia and even to a
lesser extent from France and Japan the
United States it's a different world and
here I think we need to go further back
in history to understand quite where
America currently stands we needs I
think to go back as far as 1815 a time
when Britain emerged from the Napoleonic
Wars to find everybody else bankrupt all
the other great powers on on their
uppers and Britain alone as a kind of in
a in a completely unique position of
economic and military superpower
this was a kind of monitor pool of world
and it remained a such for much of the
19th century despite occasional
skirmishes of the periphery of the
empire with with the Russians in to a
lesser extent with the French and I
think this is much more of a parallel
it's a parallel also in the way that the
United States can fight short peripheral
Wars very much in the way that british
gunboat diplomacy operated in the age of
Palmerston so the Americans today have
the option to wage gunship diplomacy and
altercations and muted apologies towards
China really form a part of the same
pattern the difference seems to me is
still one of will and perhaps also
resources the British looked at trouble
spots they looked say it
Western Africa as indeed we look at
Sierra Leone today and concluded that
something had to be done to prevent
large parts of the world descending into
a kind of permanent anarchy
I think the impulse in the United States
today is simply to look away from these
kinds of mess and regard them as simply
not relevant to the interests of the
American electorate or the interest of
the British you lecture
never matter terribly much to Palmerston
but they mattered enough and the impulse
of the British electorate most obvious
when you consider the way they
campaigned to the destruction of slavery
in the slave trade within Britain's
sphere of influence was a crucial fact
it's that moral impulse the moral
impulse to do good abroad which seems to
me so much weaker in America today next
question
right behind you is the microphone
well-heeled and RK solar do you lament
the collapse of the austro-hungarian
Empire do you lament the death of Tito
is there going to be a third question
yes I think we get where he's going well
Gladstone once said show me anywhere on
the map one place where Austria has done
good and I think I'm too much of the
other of a liberal at heart to lament
the passing of austria-hungary
which especially since it was so woeful
II self-inflicted they did choose the
means of their own destruction and they
choose chose the most terrible I think
it's extremely dangerous to lament the
passing of any great multinational
entity of any great Empire sometimes I'm
accused and I thought this would be your
third question of lamenting the passing
of the British Empire I don't think
that's really the function of the
historian these institutions were in a
sense selfish
and I think the same applies to Tito one
cannot simply wring one's hands and say
oh if only they had retained an
authoritarian regime in which ethnic
conflict was submerged was kept down by
the iron fist that simply isn't and
wasn't an option I think the question we
have to ask ourselves is whether there's
any way that the kind of institutional
assumptions we make in Britain and even
more in America about the need to
establish democracy is there any way
that we can adapt our techniques to the
reality of ethnic conflict in
disintegrating multinational entities
and I think there has to be it's very
clear looking at the ruins of Yugoslavia
today that if we are to avoid Perpetual
a recurrent ethnic cleansing there needs
to be a self-confident prolonged foreign
presence in the contested areas of
Bosnia Herzegovina and Kosovo we are
going to be there for a long time and
the great problem that this raises in
American minds is but that's not
democratic and we cannot run mandates or
a colonial policy
in a region like the Balkans and at the
same time say that we're for promoting
democracy and my response to that is the
rule of law first democracy second and
we need decades to establish the rule of
law to establish the habit of settling
disputes through courts and Parliament's
rather than with machineguns then so be
it
the great danger it seems to me that has
underpinned so much American
intervention ISM in the last 10 or 20
years has been its short-term nature the
exit strategy is already being discussed
before the troops have even been sent in
there can't be quick exits in these
situations in a sense we have to build
our own austria-hungary's we have to be
our own teachers if we're to prevent
certain regions of the world becoming
permanent genocide or nightmares and
that I think is the harsh conclusion
which very few Americans are certainly
view very few American voters are
prepared to accept next question
Jonathan Paris Oh would you wait for the
microphone Jonathan Paris a couple few
years ago I co-edited a volume called
the politics of post Suharto Indonesia
so I want to take you where you're
already going and suggest that ethnic
conflict if you go to Singapore you'll
find hatred between Chinese Indians and
Malays as strong as anywhere in
Indonesia but that the Malays the
Malaysians and the Singaporeans had the
luxury of being British colonies
Indonesia had the misfortune of being a
Dutch colony and by that I mean that you
see the rule of law the court system the
legal system the development of
institutions much more firmly settled in
the in those first two countries than in
Indonesia and what Suharto was able to
do was to collapse all of the weak
institutions to begin with around his
family and if he became like a mayor of
Chicago and so to speak so when he left
you had no institutions to hold in to
reign in the the latent ethnic tension
whereas in Singapore if you're if you
walk around and you're caught with a
knife you could get capital punishment
so you have a very strong overlay of
authoritarian rule of law so the
question is given that Indonesia
doesn't have historically the British
experience how can they get this under
control just latent ethnic tension under
control without bringing in another
Suharto well I wish I had an answer to
that question I think it's the most
alarming prospects for Asian stability
in the foreseeable future I confess to
not being an expert as you are on
Indonesia and in the sense I very
rapidly retreat into what I know from
the foreign pages of the Financial Times
which is probably a good deal less than
most people know here let me try and
answer that in a kind of historical vein
I think the interesting thing about the
legacy of British Empire is that we
can't assume it's permanent there
clearly was certainly into the 1960s an
obvious correlation between political
stability and British presence as
opposed to the presence of other
colonizing parts which generally
speaking did not do the job so well of
establishing the rule of law the tragedy
and it's most obvious in a country like
Zimbabwe former Rhodesia is that these
institutions no matter how firmly they
were established ultimately can be and
are being demolished and there's nowhere
in the world where the rule of law is
being more systematically destroyed than
in regards some Bob way today so in a
sense even even the conclusion are at
least a British if you like a British
legacy gave a country a chance of
establishing stable and institutions and
stable rule of law even that hope seems
to me to be one that wanes as time
passes I'm not sure what is going to
happen in Indonesia my hunch is though
this there will not be another sonata a
nor will there be another British Empire
capable of imposing peaceful resolution
and that what we are likely to see in
them in future is a great deal more of
that ethnic conflict with Jules has
already become such a a terrifying
aspect of the person heart Akira I'm in
tantor in the middle of the room as the
colleague of yours Timothy Garton ash
spoke here and he wrote a book which is
a useful complement to yours a history
of the present I think he comes out a
bit more optimistic than you that even
without the intervention of a Pax
Americana
there would be the spread of democratic
values over ancient hatreds in spite of
the fact that that empires like the you
Slav Empire began to disintegrate in the
ten years he studied how would you
compare your thesis with two Timothy
Garton ashes yes I I have great
admiration for Tim Goff Nash he's a very
good friend of mine I question whether
you can be a historian of the present
and his claim at the beginning of that
excellent book that he has the advantage
over future historians of having been
there strikes me as highly questionable
to say the least this is of course his
great disadvantage when it comes to
understanding the future of the Balkans
close reading of what Tim writes about
Kosovo for example reveals firstly that
his position has changed between
editions of the New York Review of Books
secondly that his experience of being
there he confesses this himself is
really part of that phenomenon we know
in Fleet Street as war tourism which is
that you fly in as the great commentator
talk to a few people pose for a few
snaps and then head back to the security
since a Deniz College Oxford to write it
off and finally the great he was a
friend you want to hear what he says
about me and finally when the great
theory emerges from these observations
it is that sooner or later all European
states will be ethnically homogenous
statements and I think he says and in a
footnote interestingly just to prove
that he is really an academic that
there's a law and the law is that any
state which has ethnic minorities
accounting for more than 20% of the
population is in the long run not viable
which is a really hard line that xenian
kind of view of the the self-determining
nature of political culture and I just
think that's wrong I think it's wrong
because if we believe that then we are
heading for a really very very torrid
21st century I also don't think that it
necessarily follows from what has been
happening in say Bosnia has a governor
there are parts of the world you just
can't split up into ethnically
homogeneous states other than at
unacceptably high human cost so in the
cash Nexus I questioned the Garton ash
theory which which although it's
temptingly simple doesn't seem to me in
fact to square with what is it
politically desirable in the foreseeable
future now I sentence if I was really
rubbishing in there which I didn't mean
at all to do because I think he is a
brilliant journalist a brilliant writer
and when people come to try to
understand the history of the collapse
of communism
they will be referred by historians to
guard Nash's commentaries particularly
on what happened in Poland which are
brilliant and and I think unique but
it's not history it's something
different from that it's the primary
sources from which history will be
written but I think maybe Tim is
deluding himself in thinking that you
can write history there and then as it
happens Jo
Thank You Joel motley um the heart of my
question goes to the tension between
military activities and major Wars and
democracy and and our history I think is
you know pretty sharply marked by these
tensions and we've had to mobilize of
his Civil War was the work worse but
over one World War two where they're the
political cost if you will of repressing
serve use and so forth and the the
trade-off between spending money and
other things quite severe and this is in
your own history as well and perhaps
back to the Greeks where people talked
about how democracies are very slow to
get going for war but once they do they
do a great job so there is this inherent
difficulty and I think you ought to
perhaps help us by reflecting on that a
bit whether Churchill or Roosevelt
talked about it the frustration of
getting ready for World War two because
the society was just fundamentally not a
military and maybe the hour will permit
me to bring the question current to say
that while the bases in Germany look
like anachronism zuv the last war as a
European perhaps you can enlighten us on
the sense that some of us have that fear
of a united Germany with a new attitude
that it doesn't have now happily but
could have is still a very real threat
for Russians and Eastern Europeans and
and our our presence there is not really
just a throwback but maybe a very
current means of keeping the lid on well
thank you for those questions on mindful
at the time so I'll try and answer them
as succinctly as I can the great problem
you were absolutely right and something
that the book tries to tackle the great
problem that the hugely wealthy but
increasingly democratic Britain and the
Democratic United States faced in the
20th century was the despite being
Kannamma Clee substantially wealthier
than their their potential foes their
democratic institutions tended to cut
defense spending in peacetime
and ruled out the kind of precautionary
military mobilization that might have
made a real difference in the run-up to
1949 in the run-up to 1939 when
particularly Germany was not
sufficiently deterred to risk a European
conflict I have thought a lot about this
and come to the conclusion that this is
really the fundamental problem of 20th
century history that authoritarian
regimes and I kind of simplify this by
talking in terms of of a kind of
anglo-american model in which democratic
institutions are our Paramount and
setting priorities and attack a
totalitarian model in which an
undemocratic elite can mobilize a
society using coercion and propaganda
well in advance of any external threat
this is the fundamental problem namely
that although these totalitarian regimes
are economically way inferior can never
compete economically with the Western
economies they are superb at destruction
in a sense there they're not interested
ultimately in production their real
strength lies in destruction that's
what's they're good at and the initial
damage done in the first phases of both
the world wars
by the non-western powers to use a
simple shorthand is staggering when you
work out the net body count in the world
wars really by air by that measure
Britain and her allies should have lost
both wars because the Germans and their
arse kill vastly more people than they
lose of their own and that's the that is
the trouble you really don't need a
great par with the equivalent GNP of the
United States to be threatened a
relatively small rogue state can inflict
horrendous damage thanks to the enormous
growth of destructive technology in the
late 20th century it can inflict
colossal damage on an unprepared
economic superpower and in the sense
coming back to an earlier question well
what are the threats
I think the threats are quite different
the threats can be carried in a
briefcase and in that sense you know the
United States is actually
all vulnerable than the British Empire
was too incredibly cheap hugely
destructive technology that can be
deployed a by rogue states more or less
at will
and to me the only amazing thing is that
terrorism hasn't become more of a
feature yes of American life but I'm
certain it will Larry Larry court from
the council let me follow up on that
because one of the criticisms of
Kennedy's book was that he took an
unnatural period right at between the
end of World War two and the start of
the Cold War then he said Americans
share of GDP a world GDP drop but if you
go back and look at average it returned
to normal
let me follow it up with defense Betty
you picked the highest year of American
spending in the Cold War period you take
a look at what we spent on average in
the Cold War it's 325 billion dollars
that's exactly what we spend today so
there has been no no real decline
similarly if you take the example of the
bases we are in those bases not to to
deal with the situation in Germany
they're jumping off points we have tried
to get bases in other parts of the world
we lost the bases in the Philippines
when I was in government we tried like
heck to get a lot of bases in the
Persian Gulf area where you have limited
access and so the idea that the United
States is not doing what it should
doesn't really add up now we you might
argue as you just did that we're
preparing for the last war with these
forces that we by are not dealing with
the real threats but it's not for lack
of effort and not for lack of
understanding the problem yes thank you
also did me the service of answering
that second question the previous
speaker raised which I completely ducked
inadvertently it wasn't it wasn't
anything other than absent-mindedness on
my part um briefly defense expenditure
the real measure that matters in fact is
is not adjusted for inflation but
adjusted for economic growth and a 2.9
percent of American gross domestic
product the current defense budget is
of the GNP and and in fact then we would
still be protecting you know our
interest around the world you I mean you
can't penalize this country for having
tremendous economic growth in the 90s
and with that with that measure no but
you can say that a country that is
enjoying enormous economic growth has
the capability to increase its military
capability and I think that's really my
point that allowing the defense budget
to in relative terms to decline to a
point lower than at any time since the
interwar period I mean almost we're
heading towards a situation when the
number of Americans in the armed
services as a proportion of the
populations as low as it was in a before
the American Civil War it's an
extraordinary demilitarization that
we're living through now it seems to me
the problem with that and the problem
with what you've just said about the
military bases is simply one of what is
actually doable now if a major collapse
of order were to occur in Asia say in
Indonesia
if the stability of America's allies
were to be threatened by minor rogue
states it seems to me clear that the
American military though is it absolute
terms the best resourced in the world
would be extremely hesitant to intervene
the interventions that have occurred in
the last 10 or so years have been
strikingly short in duration and the
emphasis on minimizing casualties as I
think genuinely impeded or what the US
is prepared to do while at the same time
there isn't really a willingness on the
American part to allow multinational
institutions under the auspices of the
UN to do more by simply paying
Ukrainians and others to act as
mercenaries in countries like Sierra
Leone or or or Ronda so I do think that
it's a legitimate question to ask if
America enjoys the highest level of
prosperity in all history should it not
be prepared to consider using a
proportion of those those resources for
something other than purely national
defense and I think that's really the
issue whether one takes so
the slack that's created by the boom
years and thinks seriously about
devoting it to not just peacekeeping but
peacemaking in those areas of the world
which are simply heart of darkness
territory that's essentially a moral
question it has nothing to do with the
national interest it's a question really
of responsibility and the responsibility
that comes with undreamt off well there
are quite a few people that want to have
at you and we have only a short time
left I'm gonna cluster a few questions
and then come back to you for a final
statement David we please keep here at
questions as short as possible
David David Marvin what n want you I was
just wondering whether drawing all these
comparisons with Britain and so forth
may miss the point I don't know I may
miss the point but in any case we don't
it seems to me have said is our priority
not extending our institutions
particularly to other parts of the world
I mean democracy can take a number of
different forms we're not extending an
empire we're not extending communism
we're not extending Nazism as those
countries tried to do or the Japanese in
their way what we're trying to do is set
up a different international a different
set of international institutions to
which all can be comes with which all
can become so entwined I'm talking about
WTO's and IMF's and all the others that
we're experimenting with a asia-pacific
economic coordination and so forth that
it will develop self interests on the
parts of all these other countries that
to cooperate to some degree in order to
save their economic livelihood and that
we have armed forces residually in a way
large though they'd be to take care of
the cases of countries that you
mentioned that aren't willing to do the
economically sensible thing or Somalia's
that collapse though it's gone on
collapsing since
and other countries that may require
some support to get out of dead-end
situations of ethnicity by the way the
minorities in the United States are now
beyond 30% and we don't seem to worry
you've been waiting for a while do you
still want to get in Charles Ferguson I
would just ask you whether you think
that perhaps the increase in ethnic
strife might be consequent upon the lack
of equitably distributed education and
Economic Opportunity in many nations
which in turn might be the result of
previous military and political
occupation and secondly if you could
provide examples of drawing on your
historical knowledge of situations in
which the long term military occupation
of foreign nations resulted in the
betterment of their social and economic
condition I'm gonna take the opportunity
to post the final question and then ask
you to sum up I share your conclusion
about the importance and the
desirability of the United States
putting the pedal to the metal and
running trying to run the show it's
probably the most stable world that one
can imagine it's worked very well for
the last several decades I just don't
think it's possible and I don't think
it's possible largely because of
American domestic politics
a set of institutions a constitution
that doesn't really have the same sort
of internationalist inclinations that
other countries do in part because of
our history in part because where we are
and so I fear that if the United States
were to pursue this sort of grand
strategy that you advocate it would
overreach you would end up in a position
where we pursued a foreign policy for
which there was no domestic support and
then we end up where Woodrow Wilson
ended up trying to aspire to a level of
engagement and ending up with nothing
well thank you for those questions I
have a tiny amount of time mere minutes
to answer
I'll do my best um the danger of
assuming that economic integration the
mighty power of credit will ensure world
peace is very well illustrated by two
books one Norman angels great illusion
and the other the recent book by a New
York Times journalist Thomas Friedman
all the three in the Lexus or was it
Nexus not Nexus both books argue that
that in a sense economic integration and
global financial integration will will
bring about a new era of peace that
Golden Arches theory of democracy that
says no two states will go to war with
one another if they both have branches
and McDonald's was actually disproved
within days of the book's publication in
in Britain by the the bombing of
Belgrade and I think the the problem
with the Norman Angell view which is
absolutely what you are have just argued
that we can allow economic
interrelationship to usher in a new year
of peace is the problem that was wrong
with arguing that in 1911 but it isn't
actually enough the Dostoyevsky in point
they fight and fight and fight seems to
me to be and that's really the whole
point of the cache Nexus to be something
that simply offering trade and
investment cannot trump violence will
happen people will not all flock to
Walmart in preference to buying a
Kalashnikov and having up one another
and at some level American foreign
policy has to put aside this I think
economic determinist utopianism it is
not going to be enough simply to let the
World Trade Organization make everybody
trade to abolish war and the issue
really seems to mean not about the
imposition of democracy that's a
contradiction in terms but the
imposition of the rule of law and
perhaps also the ensuring of improved
education certainly when robert barro
did his great study of the determinants
of economic growth in the post-war world
the the most interesting result
were a that democratic institutions
didn't matter but the things that did
matter were be at the rule of law and
see education of particular education as
it turned out of men rather than women
I've never understood quite how he
arrived at that finding but he did so in
a sense we have to be clear what the
objective is you can't just sell the
rule of law it's not a product that you
can buy at Walmart and people won't buy
it necessarily voluntarily
the issue really is how can it be
imposed in those parts of the world and
there are a great menu where it's not
wanted and I think only of the recent
events in Albania Macedonia of Sierra
Leone of East Timor Indonesia think of
the genocide in Rwanda which was allowed
to happen while the Security Council of
the United Nations fiddled niro like its
back turned and so one could go on there
are a great many trouble spots and the
attitude seems to be at the moment we
will intervene and are completely ad hoc
basis where we feel we can do it quickly
and with zero casualties it's not enough
somebody asks for an example I think it
was a country that had benefited from
long term for an occupation I'm sorry
India there's a succinctly for you will
find running out
and can I end by agreeing with with my
chair
the real problem and the reason of
course the reason that I end the book
with a question about American will
relates precisely to those chapters that
deal with democracy and its internal
ailments the chapter that deals with the
decline of healthy political parties as
a phenomenon not only in Europe but in
the u.s. the chapter that deals with
campaign finance is a a real source of
instability within the mature
democracies I am ultimately pessimistic
as you are about the willingness of
American voters to contemplate any
American GIs so much as sustaining a
scratch in a country like Sierra Leone
and I think that's why one comes back to
the future of the international
institutions the extent to which we can
make the united nations work if the
United States isn't willing to act on
its own behalf in these trouble spots
and I conclude with a statistic the
combined budget of all United Nations
programs all United Nations activities
currently amounts to 1% of the u.s.
federal budget which institution has the
real power that's the real cash Nexus
Thank You Neil for an intellectual feast
Niall Ferguson is a professor of
political and financial history at
England's Oxford University and author
of the cash Nexus money and power in the
modern world 1700 to 2000
it's published by basic books for more
information visit their website at basic
books calm 48 hours of nonfiction books
on TV you're watching booked